[Music]
welcome back to the drug my ass stop
my save files and I'm a baby you never
finish your series I was like I had to
replay everything up until this point I
hope you're happy
okay damn oh no not again
again all right I've been told that we
need to collect all the things that was
kind of obvious you need to collect all
the items for the last map
thingamajigger thingy got that your
teachers are nice keep going doing what
you're doing girl
if i some fashion department thingy i
don't know what that is and the last map
is supposed to be the scariest one so i
spent a lot of time God that word is a
kid keep rolling around in my quarters
I'm a [ __ ] cop I decide this actually
no I'm not a cop I could have made it in
the cop school
mr. fat already [ __ ] awfully I'm
simulator let's see the controls
alright we're going and going oh my god
it's the eight we're all screwed oh oh
girl the [ __ ] is that
drink it if ragged fruit wells that I
ain't your [ __ ] I'm running out of
battery
oh no need to focus first five lights
Hollett it is how you doing it's always
talked to today how am i doing in here
oh yeah oh yeah we need this here it is
come on girl we will die but we will get
the scribble fragment we need it for the
last map all right yay torn up family
make sure all that creepy [ __ ] copper
night I know he was there all right so I
think pretty much I there I find a
battery fascist [ __ ] or I just die and
restart it's not I think Diane restart
is probably easiest but the most
inconvenient
I like this other story I may be anyway
now I'm gonna die [ __ ]
yep I'm gonna die hey guys hey guys ride
makes the copying machine
alright I'm turning up the sound I don't
like this
I like it why would you do that
I didn't do anything I was just game
over you possess a heart desire
nothing's crazy what can I say we try
yes that's the same state rather we wash
all this stupid crap yeah I just want
the ramen i devour Graham I don't
understand when you find the batteries
oh no how would I go
[Music]
oh there we go
so creepy I would be scared as [ __ ] all
right we're good
I got my hat so it's not problem it's no
problemo señoras that's not a word all
right
you still turn the fastest [ __ ] like
it's good you turn too fast in this game
like like I can't keep up with this this
is too fast
it's the emulator I I tried some [ __ ]
much to do it I'm not gonna bother
anymore this game has been nothing but
trouble for me you must finish it we
don't care it's alright I understand you
don't care about me I mean I I'm not
important I just have for the only thing
everyone out why would you do why would
you okay this is Cal yay yay
all right what's going on what was that
in the security cam I doubt it's an
employer Vesely well I gotta do
something about a pervert
I took out the Fonz - I wonder who that
person was how does it take out the
phones
this is like an EMP like I just AM takes
out all the chip hundreds ain't my dad
she can do that she probably can't do
that from her fights I hear that's
possible [ __ ] this sounds creepy
alright ok say right babies knocking
over boxes there we go
all right that's normal I suppose that
was everyday just keep on falling
you found wrong oh no yes it does
now I remember are you coming from but
what's wrong with your face Jesus being
it it was a trap of course save stick
let's keep on
let's go let's call it's not problem LEM
us like this in Sweden
alright maybe you say it somewhere else
to analyze let's keep on going we're
ending to the door there there then why
all rights try this place in hey
microphone
oh here's the battery holy [ __ ] I looked
everywhere for you
what's up what's up in the microwave Oh
microwave was done someone was cooking
something how was it positive all that
microwaves going with the Internet I
mean electricity safe state
[ __ ] all right how do I turn
all right there we go Carol girl turn
around just turn around all right there
we go oh oh [ __ ] it's this hair the
[ __ ] you come from no one likes her no
one likes her oh yeah off of me uh yeah
yeah Jesus penis I don't want here no
one likes her
no fun except bald people they like her
I got Mac hit I would [ __ ] kill you I
hate that baby tingly tingly that's
another thing we're seeing Sweden I
think maybe all right
okay which one that's normal make sense
all right all right so left all right
which door men's or women's we should go
into women's is where I'm a [ __ ]
[ __ ] hey I don't think you can yeah you
can all right sweet girls guys I can t
rape you I mean anyone in here I like it
hello someone's just having diarrhea
that's fine
Wow Wow anyone in here hello hey
batteries yes eyeko line nine mine
battery ha all right sweet maybe we can
find something the others stay ah what
is this
you pee here don't tell me you pee here
freaking Japanese in there toilet I'll
never know oh these doesn't have handles
on oh this - right
nothing god damn it boy
all right let's go to the boys room cuz
I'm a man now I feel manly er that more
batteries just saying not that anyone
cares I think at least one person wrote
that down
PewDiePie feels man here alright anyone
there
that never happened any more than the
water-scarce on I guess I get old after
a while
let's go in here oh no double doors care
[Music]
hello I will get I'm on fire I'm on a
fire
I'm on a fire I guess technically I
could be on a fire huh boys men's room
boys men's room really all right oh no I
need to take a piss hey what is this oh
no oh no I don't know I
oh no get the [ __ ] out here that's how
you get the touch Halliday
ah now new [ __ ]
alright fine it's going here again thank
God for six days we're invented safe
stay the same stick you know what I mean
by that
[Music]
God dang it
alright let's go in here take a piss why
is he in the bad boys room Ben's room
boys been yeah I can't talk today oh
they [ __ ] hair everywhere Susie they
don't have to leave
why is there a bottom oh because I can
take a piss alright here we go I'm ready
to shake like a [ __ ] just hide
mother
alright good anat on it take this as
all right
oh of course Hey okay I'm Amy I may be
I got it I got it I got it I got it
[Music]
please don't come in here I feel like
that make you
yay I like that yeah I like that a lot
all right we get I don't matter like
it's free yeah yeah oh no damn it
maybe you can find a battery in here
maybe now I'm probably not all right
let's keep on rollin keep on trolling
keep on patrolling yes yes yes all right
we're good I hope
hello
and I money here I got fire
extinguishers awesome it's a high panic
they left like a crocodile face hey can
you kill a KitKat for me I would be
[ __ ] great
Oh blood oh that's fantastic likes going
there
Oh No why am I doing this I'm just a
security guard I didn't ask for any of
this I can't even open doors normally I
have some issues with door opening all
right finalists going here
no I can see through the [ __ ] door I
know this house gonna be anything there
[Music]
all right oh this is gonna be fun all
right [ __ ] don't peep at me
Jesus penis why is there so much noise
hello oh she got titties
it's fine my mom a little stole me pity
pity come on shoot him I that huh oh she
got kidded her
oh no I don't like this I don't like
this at all but my mom always said if
they have titters pity it's fine don't
worry
titties each alright so I'm assuming
this alright it's alright even though it
makes me feel kind of uncomfortable even
though I should probably be happy
because there's like potatoes everywhere
but I don't know I don't like it
what is his dress
why does this ugly [ __ ] not show me
your tater girl just tell me I'd hit it
huh don't hold my key to the tingly
dress don't [ __ ] with me now dress now
oh no oh oh no oh snap oh oh I'm gonna
keep oh it is it's all right it's all
right I got did it yeah all right you
see that turning dress no one can do
that only I can do that
all right let's pick this up and then I
have to go oh yeah is that oh no please
I get like everything everywhere the
[ __ ] rat I hate yeah Wow Oh nope
nobody no I'm not gonna play anymore
like and favorite if you enjoyed and
I'll see you tomorrow
I got some breakfast
[Music]
all right